[Music]
last weekend a box office record was
broken but I'm not talking about a good
one
all right the children's movie the og
loves in the big balloon adventure I'm
gonna say that title again the movie
loves in the big balloon adventure had
the worst opening weekend in all of
cinema history yes the og loves were
created by the same guy who created the
Teletubbies and yeah if you haven't
heard of this eg love's film here's a
very small sample
[Music]
when you're saying that didn't do well
you didn't do well oh that's the climax
of the film
that's where you'll find out the sled is
rosebud that is the big moment of the
movie well anyway I wanted to find out
more about because that just fascinates
me and yes thing nobody went to buy it
so I have invited one of its stars on
the show please welcome ladies and
gentlemen one of the og loves let's get
him in here hi everyone I hope you're
all having a new gear if ik de whoo yeah
okay I'm sorry I have to ask you first
of all why is your face all but an
adorable one yeah whatever okay tell us
what went wrong with this movie I have
no idea
the okie love's movie has everything
kids love balloons talking vacuum
cleaners shrieking voices puppets with
dead eyes plus every kid's favorite
celebrities Toni Braxton and Chaz Pawan
Terry
[Laughter]
just Palmiter I'm sorry that Jazzmatazz
yeah yeah in a kilt it sounds awful how
much did this thing cost seriously sixty
million dollars sixty million dollars
okay how much did it make a new Gillian
dollars stop screwing around with me
there's no such numbers an Aggie Gillian
how much is that in real money fifteen
dollars okay fifteen dollars and
Counting okay but it's okay we've
learned from our mistakes and we're
already working on a sequel it takes
place in an abandoned sock Factory and
it stars James Carville and the tan mom
that's even worse you should go I know
they've already fired me so long
everybody
[Music]